oh who needs carlson when you have peak
eric i don't know if i'm
if i'm peaking today i'll try to peek
i peaked a few weeks ago i posted it to
youtube
the youtube video is called i peaked
yeah i streamed tennis yesterday
my second ever tennis stream
for my channel i figured out the
settings so it was watchable
had to stream in 720p i ripped my pants
i took a dive and my pants ripped
so r.i.p
yeah you can always watch the vod there
are a few uh fun clips
and thank you football and chess three
two
okay title arena time i haven't played
one of these in a while
playing fm so i'm not berserking i'm
gonna stick with my main main repertoire
um probably my bullet repertoire
london time i'll play knight d2 i'll go
for this trap
so d5 knight e5 whoa airbus driver
gifting subs so i have a double threat
of this and this
um am i just winning material i think
i'm winning material bishop d6 is i
think the best move there
but this is a very very pleasant start
so i want to take and then threaten
knight
here and the queen and this
yeah um move the bishop back
i can take and the knight will escape
this way
and then this way so it returns it took
the rook and then returned to its
promised land um
go in for the kill so i probably want to
play
like if we trade on e5 i want to
remove the knight and play queen h5
also some idea of winning the pawn
um should defend the knight
yeah i'm gonna play solidly be patient
yeah now i'll go in for the kill
unless knight h7 is played i'm probably
h4
is this mating i think it's oh the
knight defends
so i can take and then oh e5 hangs oh
i messed this up i kind of messed it up
should still be winning though
opponents fighting from kudos to my
opponents
i hung up thing wow so i'm down material
after such a good opening but i'm going
to win on time
i better win on time
don't hurt me
i mean black was on the verge of mating
me wow
that's a wake-up call man that's such a
good opening this is uh um
this is what i show in this uh st louis
chess called london lecture
it's the ashwin trap there's a grand
master who had that
that trapped twice in the same
tournament
um but i got away with a win i'll repeat
the london
and now i'm slightly more awake
hopefully
okay so we have one of these oh f6
f6 i think bishop b5 and c4
okay i know e6 is uh
some idea you're all taken and
develop that's kind of a new way of
playing for black
take and go back let me put the queen on
a3 bishop d6 ideas
um
bishop f8 is coming okay here i can play
bishop d6
i think is okay
oh no that's actually a good move
i'm losing the exchange i'm down a lot
of time too
um
now the f1 it's complicated
but more complicated in black's favor
and b4
all i need is like one fork
this is bad
ah
that's rough opponent played well it's
kind of a cool line this f6 idea
f6 g5 uh oh playing strong player let's
play stafford or
not play one of these
play f5 so this is a lavi rosman line
um d4
eric i'm confusing my prep go me yeah
thanks for that um
i think i can take bishop c5 and
castling
oh levy beat me in this recently
be safe knight d4 coming
it looks like a nice position
looks like a very nice position
pile up on this pawn or this pawn
a good move
that's a free bishop
wow didn't even try to try and flag me
that was nice that's a high rating too
let's go
thanks for the great content eric
oh thank you lazy karu and vampire
chicken what's up vampire i almost
missed you there
was the one saying go go eric thanks so
much
that was good luck sub oh opponent gets
stronger
okay i want to play d5
yeah this is actually um a box playing
the bus line here
forget what i play
just have to improvise
okay this looks nice
um should now have allowed that
it's still interesting have this move
oh no my bishop oh no
if takes i've queen d7
okay life goes on oh my pawn
this move h5 coming
what is this i want to play this move
man black has connect four
and monster pawns now ah
have to go after this pawn
triple battery
and do some reorganizing of the
furniture
i just want to invade oh i don't want to
trade queens though
dirty flag time
played well ah i was hoping for like
some weird stalemate something but
that was rough it's nice opening though
been watching your streams on youtube
two wins two losses
support you on twitch now love your
content eric
thanks so much really appreciate that
welcome to twitch
thanks for the bits just saw you
and i were both born in evanston neil oh
uh yeah that's um
wait i have to focus uh what is this
okay opponent didn't fall for the trap
but actually it's not a bad position
have some uh some
activity
yeah i grew up in in skokie which is
right next to evanston play this move
love your streams oh love you too
thanks for that vander
something something
okay so i have a time advantage
i'm down the pawn but there's some
attacking potential
that's the thing with playing this like
this dirty gambit is
like you're just gonna be down the pawn
but i don't mind
i'm quite so solid
you see four at the right moment or not
oh no my pawns nice i'm actually in with
netca at the moment oh nice
yeah illinois has a nice like
flourishing chest scene
play this move
i'm going for the the kill king power
let's go on some nice
oh white's defending
this should be winning
there we go
whoa it's a raid i don't know who's
raiding because i have to convert this
first
but thanks for raiding how am i mate
with two queens
there we go whoa it's gotham chess
what's up gotham chess
thanks for reading appreciate that shout
out to levy
that's a giant raid lavi i played
against your opening
a few games ago this vienna this vienna
opening
i still need to buy your course
i really appreciate it despite you
calling me a liar on twitter
i do appreciate it someone use the
gotham command
raid from gotham and nice to re-sub
yeah if you're just joining this is uh
the lyches tyler arena
it's two hours of bullet against title
players
and i'm doing decently i have three wins
and
two losses and now i'm playing a
reverse grand prix oh it's a fork and
white's gonna get forked again
because this is a mate threat let's go
shout out to levy shout out to levi's
twitch channel oh what does this move
to play this i guess i'm not winning the
rook
but i'll take the bishop and
put the pawn there
yeah shout out to lovey's twitch channel
and youtube channel
and twitter and instagram he's very
active on all the platforms
uh
i want to do things but let's be safe
and keen safety first oh i can do things
never mind
and do things with the knight knight d3
incoming
hmm what does this move
that was onyx white white forked uh
himself
kind of there okay now i can take here
that's all i wanted to do all along
i'll check and then i'll take and rook
g8
so for f6 it's almost mate
um okay we'll trade rooks
let's not blunder a queen
there's a lot of ways to blunder a queen
here
there we go so this is nice because i
can just play on the light squares
and take free stuff
okay
okay gotta stay focused
the goal is top top 100
let's go i have a streak this is my
first that was the first
two wins in a row this tournament eight
points
why did he sell fork uh he was probably
being generous
as an early christmas gift
i'm gonna try and hold off on giving
early gifts
that's a move play queen b1 tricky move
um okay i want to play f3
because always play f3
wait i just lost a pawn
that didn't work at all but i can take
away black's casting rights
forcing the bond cloud
man black has so many pawns black still
has all eight pawns
but i have one half open file
okay i'm gonna have to bond cloud my
king too
with the queenside bong cloud
i'm not feeling comfy here
okay let's do the traditional bon cloud
i'll probably just want to run away
now the queen is so out of play let's
get it back into play
so if oh white one or black one connect
five
but i win a pawn
don't hurt me
finding this
oh let's trade
take stuff
pond diamond
what is this wow what was that end game
what was that end game
that was like the worst played end game
ever
so i had a pawn t like a small
t not a big t
but then the t was um
was kind of decapitated and then
black took a pawn i could have taken
back but then i played f6 because i
always play f6
and then black had a choice which pawn
to take but push the pawn
with check not realizing i could take
and then we both made a new queen and
then i won on time
okay what a game so that was my third
win in a row
let's go started playing again during
covet your videos helped me get to 1000.
oh
that's a good tier keep it up thanks for
that
i'm hall okay i'll play london
or benoni gambit accepted tricky line
that's a fun line for a bullet
because i have the two bishops i have
the d6 square
black star squares are weak
and now it's just about positional play
i always play king b1
probably go for some maybe some sort of
king side attack
f4 now this pawn is
never mind
okay i just want to play like alpha zero
to defend this pawn
okay we'll play this position not
entirely sure what to make of this
let's sack i didn't want to lose g2
okay now i'm winning the f pawn
i should press an f in the chat for the
f pawn
let's solidify
oh so many f's in the chat and chad is
being so respectful
how do i win this i don't know how to
win this
yeah my time too
this move check
check no
this is bad
i have five seconds left
no my rook we need more f's
ah
oh it's such a nice position too at
least i feel respected
oh what's with it sapphire gamba time
i have to soothe the pain with a
stafford except this is not a stafford
what is this
oh oh no yeah this is a really bad
opening
i don't know what i'm doing here i'm
tilted after that last game
but i'm surviving kind of
let's trap a bishop maybe
that's a fancy move that's a really
fancy move
it's all about time though i'm getting
outplayed
defend
i think i'm alive
but not really i might lose this
don't meet me stop hurting me
oh no i lost a lot of rain points there
too ah
well played okay no more
no more that's my first two losses in a
row
it's gonna be a long tournament okay
let's berserk and let's
un-tilt myself by playing tilty openings
um i'm very close to mating here
very close to mating
now this is this is a nice way to until
myself
this is meat okay that was nice
need more games like that okay
staff for gamba time or four nights time
copycat time i should get a cat
says lead school oh lead school oh
thanks brian
i appreciate the third person talking
um it's close
i meant to play rook d8 i'm losing a
pawn
but not really okay threatening mate
threatening this let's go
attacking wow that defended everything
but i'm up material up the exchange
can trade queens time is fine
pawns are smiling
they're gonna pile up on this pawn
okay i want i want a v-shape for victory
don't mess with my pawn v
i always play g5
oh no i'm getting forked hi
how's it going j davis thanks for
subbing
the pawn v survives kind of
let's put the king in the heart of the v
i'll make a sandwich
no i flagged no how is white faster than
me i had a queen
oh no ah
oh that's so sad i feel so broken
alexa play sad music
the station sad songs on amazon music
alexa stop making me sad
okay here's ruined my day here's your
depressing fact
what curiosity rover on mars sings happy
birthday to itself
every year that's really sad probably
the loneliest birthday in the solar
system
alexa stop it that was really sad
i told you to stop making me sad
okay playing cash vampire
let's recover from the sadness
uh
to play i want to attack a pawn
play g4 look at this move if on poisson
i win the bishop
black wants to hurt me
okay so i'm down on time and my king
side's kind of weak but apart from that
it's okay i'm gonna stack the exchange
oh i wanna play g5
alexis stop being so rude
yeah i mean i was trying i was just
unintentionally rude
i don't know what my plan is here
my plan is not to get hurt
physically or emotionally
push upon when in doubt push
upon
that was probably a bad move did i
i may have had made in one there
hey that's meat ah i didn't even realize
i was meat let's go
alexa play happy music
stop i'm happy now
i don't want to get copyrighted
okay we have a london line oh
okay so the plan here is usually rook c1
and b4
and laugh at the queen
yeah the queen is very laughable now
hahaha
alexa laughs
do you not know how to laugh victory bit
simrocin let's go in rosain let's go
let's go oh look at these nights they're
so beautiful
what's going on a huge cluster of pieces
i don't know what's going on just
attacking a knight
okay so the pawn is pinned in two
directions
i'm attacking a rook
oh but black's attacking my queen oh but
i'm winning a pawn
but not really
life is so complicated
but opponents perplexed very perplexing
check
yeah g6 was a better move there
um let's check
i could queenside castle or kingside
castle
safer move
oh that was a really bad move
let's go oh
opponent was fast but i was faster let's
go
hey it's lily what's up lily shout out
to
hope you're doing well good to see you
top hundred let's go
98 oh i'm playing casablanca
uh strong player but not streaming
but he does have a twitch channel people
can check them out
okay
play one of these
yeah so these things are weak not sure
if this accomplishes anything
it looks fun though and nice knight
and targeting f2
go for some trade c4 is attacked
always play f6
put the queen on e7 oh that's a good
move
look at this move it takes i take so
defending the knight with tactics
okay let's put the king safe safe and
sound and then
fork or not really
that was a good move
what do i do here i could take it
okay down on time position is decent
though
i want to play bishop c5 and attack
i'm up on time position is very nice
threatening mate
what is this what is this
let's go i actually meant to play queen
g2 but i mouse slipped checkmates
okay that was nice it was hard-fought
game
okay back on the streak let's go
so oh rebecca harris leading the
tournament
and dania the monster oh wait let's not
berserk
that was that was very reflexive too i
just want one stafford gambit
let's go oh stafford declined
this is fine can't complain
a solid structure
um it's getting spicy
the queen is kind of on a journey
so white has a bishop hair
but i have the only knight on the board
the knights are sometimes better in
bullets
because they can be trickier
free bishop
i think it's important my bishop defends
a rook
so there's no takes takes
some idea of this
attacking attacking attacking
am i getting mated
no i'm getting more material
i'm feeding cuddling the night
it's a slightly annoying move
oh i just blundered the thing
opponent doesn't take it oh i'm
threatening bishop h2 let's go
wow so i just wondered the bishop there
but it worked out i play the game
against you my username in chess
com is the one i am donating with
um in the future but you'll have to be
patient
i'm playing a tournament right now and
uh i'm gonna keep playing the
tournaments but
every usually every week i'll dedicate
at least one
stream to playing viewers uh usually on
the chess
thanks for the donation insane how even
for 2500 players it's still hard to see
queens moving sideways
yeah yeah board vision is so important
especially in uh in bullet chest
okay so i'm trying to play solidly here
i have a nice alpha zero pawn
might be losing this pawn or not
i play g4 g5 coming
could be a long game closed position
ooh a very sheer of like move
i want to play f3 oh okay i think it's
still okay
win back the pawn almost forgot about
this
okay oh i'm losing material yeah my
thing is pinned
oops i'm losing more material
i'm down on time too
but maybe it's not so bad
i have comp
do i do this it's so reckless
let's do let's do it anyway
so i want to check
and eventually mate that's not working
though
preventing rook g8s
that was a nice position too i lost
material in the center
it's kind of unfortunate thank you samus
one six one two subbing with prime and
um
oh thanks meat is my favorite meal
uh with 300 bits and thanks again skye
xxi for donation
i'm playing uh gawain jones verde notes
strong player grand master
going into some theory here
i'll leave the tension
yeah white's usually slightly better in
these sort of positions
i'm getting the bishop hair oh that's a
fork
this move
just have to hunker down
trying to hug the rook with my pieces
have this move
and go for the trade of rooks
okay now i feel more comfortable
but still slightly not comfortable
what knights move backwards even
grandmasters forget night nights move
backwards
okay it still takes work to win this
though
i'm so confused
let's go oh am i not winning
no
ah ah i was up at night
uh he was fast and yeah
it's hard to play sometimes like nights
are so complicated um
i should not have trash talked
okay kind of a streaky series of games
still top hundred oh i played this
opponent before
had a nice kind of wind type thing
this is a slightly different line than
earlier
okay so i want to go for this sort of
classic attack
i always play king b1
it's actually kind of pleasant
um still go for this
oh black wants to hurt me
play c3
i have to be very very careful here oh
i'm getting mated in three
opponent sees it but it's stalling oh it
doesn't see it really wow i thought my
opponent was just toying around with me
okay that's nice i was about to resign
too
oops that's still a difficult position
oh i can take the work with check but
not quite
okay now we're what is this
what's going on here am i losing
am i surviving
i think i'm still alive barely
um
there goes all my things
ah
hmm okay so that's three losses in a row
not the end of the world it's a long
tournament
have a good position if i get the
advantage i can't get too relaxed
i still want i haven't had a single
staffer gambit accepted
until now let's go
let's go just win fold head wait didn't
i trap this person in the same lines
at some point
maybe not
i've had this trap so many times okay so
queen f3 is the best move but it's still
uh not so good for white bishop g4
coming
um still bishop g4
this is all still preparation
and then takes and castle
a nice positional advantage here
white's king is stuck
i guess the game goes on kind of
a white surviving
okay let's keep attacking
oh yeah so the queen is tied down to the
knights
put the bishop here what's the best way
to do this
i could go for the flag
oh this mate okay and it's a skewer the
mate skewer
okay so i stopped the bleeding i lost
three in a row
i won the game i'm at 30 points leader
has 65 points
rebecca harris man
so a goal is to to get to 2700
it's within range
okay we're playing some weird kind of
dubious opening
but looks playable
and preventing knight b5
that's a good move
i can take here
maybe 94. it's complicated
just like a life
oh got forked i'm still alive
barely
barely actually i'm very alive here
i'm losing a pawn but this is skewered
oh there's a cool tactic oh but not
going into it
play b5
i just got to play fast
i want to take or that
oh
no ah
i had a nice position i was just too
slow
um that's okay though
okay so now i have i have the same goal
as earlier
to get into the top hundred
i guess that's that's the nice thing
about failing
is that then you can have your your
goals to chase after
okay we're gonna play
i'll play um oh can i set up the trap
not quite so box playing a hippo
and i'm playing a crab kind of delayed
i'm crab to try and be solid
i'll just try and enjoy the space
advantage
i want to leave the pawn here to prevent
g5
i'll put the king on g2
a very closed position but this is nice
because now i have the c file
i'm just going for the squeeze
and it's like making orange juice
oh and check
what is this
my pieces are optimized what do i do
here
now my pawn i want to play e6
it's a breakthrough
okay this idea because the bishop is
pinned
now it's skewered
oh my meeting
i think it's time for the music eric oh
the music oh
haven't played music in a while
wait we don't need the music i'm okay i
won the game i was about to lose that
i was on the verge of flagging
but thanks for reminding me mr willie
hammer maybe towards the end we'll get
some
some haul of the mountain king
i'll prepare it
wait where is it youtube
i should really bookmark it
okay um stafford gambit maybe
oh king's gambit what is this
threatening queen h4
play f6
love you always oh i love you too thanks
for that asgram
okay so we have some weird opening
i'm gonna maneuver the knight to c7
defend the pawn
let's expand
that's a great move
maybe this
that didn't work okay so i'm down upon
getting attacked
being greedy i don't think this is going
to end well
knight g6
what's going on this is not going to end
well
i don't know what to do here that was a
really good move
i feel so attacked
this is going to suck the queen it's
easier to play
what does this move
i'm so slow ah i came back there i want
all of white's pieces too
oh i was about to pull a miracle
that was much easier for me to pre-move
because white had to like move around
the king
okay it's part of life don't tilt
deep breath keep playing openings
i always play king b1
this is a fun line especially when they
allow bishop h6 and
and this i don't mind this move because
i
have a3 i mean this is an idea
and then knight c3
this is still pretty much prep
if takes never mind okay let's take here
get the queen in
so black's still alive but it is
pleasant for white
that's a free rook i'm bored vision
okay
i'm trying to mentally recover from all
my my sorrows
okay
oh wow zavin chasmud zavin chasmud won
the
the warm-up but i think i'm ahead of him
okay we're gonna have this opening
this is a fun line against the nimzo
larsen
played some similar stuff against nemo
yesterday
i want to go for this
throw in bishop b4 and take away white's
casting rights
this is kind of a crazy idea if takes i
take and
i mean white's getting three pieces for
the queen but it looks fun
i have queen g5 in the end forking the
pawns
moving all the pawns
except not these
okay open the file i just want to make
another queen
um let's lift a rook
what do i play here rook c2
rook f2 it's a weird position
oh that's a free rock opponent made the
same mistake my previous opponent made
boardvision okay that was a fun game
kind of cool combination interesting
material imbalance
okay oh zab and chess moon we're tied
oh i'm playing akash shout out to akash
fellow streamer
vip in the channel uh oh he's playing
this
stuff is he gonna play okay not playing
bishop c5
oh but he's playing it here is he gonna
fall into this trap is he gonna pre-move
knight e7
oh he didn't pre-move knight e7 oh i
wanted to counter trap him
dad you didn't listen to my video
yeah b4 was is my secret uh poison
against this opening
ah i'm so disappointed
um i'm losing pawns and a rook
and i'm down a ton of time
let's fight back so akash is a former
teammate of mine we both competed
for the university of illinois chess
team
years ago
and we used to play like over-the-board
blitz and bullet matches
for cookies wait i should stop talking
i'm in trouble here do you think the
initial position
of the pieces is the best one i'm in
lots of trouble
maybe i don't know
i don't have time to answer that
fork time
oh the queen can't defend the rook okay
i'm up a bishop oh that was that was
very wise by akash
just want to take
you
dirty flag i'm sorry akash you played
well
you called my you you didn't pre-move
97.
i wanted you to pre-move 97.
okay gigi shout out to akash
people can check him out on twitch he
has nice content
okay top hundred let's go on the streak
oh okay
what is this oh that's not a free pawn
i think i'm giving white a free pawn
or no i'm taking a free pawn bishop
takes g7 i'm queen g5
board vision
yeah queen takes is playable
okay there's f4 but then i take and the
knight has no moves to
safely defend the rook
oh i allowed rook g1 there oops
rocchio is still a threat but white
resigns okay that was nice
okay so four in a row let's go 64th
place
or 63rd place 44 points
rebecca has 81 so no carlson
but there's a penguin
okay we'll play reverse grand prix
against whatever this is
more than halfway keep it up oh yeah oh
thanks
thanks for that the moral support
appreciate it
richter's neighbor
um to do move the bishop maybe this way
um okay should expand
oh the thing i forgot there's two
attackers
okay i'm gonna defend the pawn and then
try and win this thing
go after this pawn
and much worse here unfortunately
bring the king in
i have to try something
so i'm threatening the fork i mean i can
just defend
this is kind of a fork
i'm starting c2 now
how about white's queening but i have c2
oh that's meat oh i got mated i saw 92
but that was a better move
this is a bit of a weird question but
how do you deal with frustration when
slash if you lose
it's been making me play less recently
because i get somewhat mad when i lose
you need the right perspective that
losing is part of the game
you need lots of experience losing to be
able to cope with it
but after a loss rather than getting
emotional
sometimes you just have to reflect like
what exactly went wrong
you have to ask yourself the right
questions like after losing don't ask
yourself why you're so bad at
but ask yourself like what went wrong
what
could be improved and
hopefully that will make you a better
player because every loss should really
make you a stronger player
if you have the right perspective
does this work i should start with this
and then i still want to play this
fishing time take my bait
do it do it
opponent doesn't do it i could i can i
could take this
okay now i'm going fishing wait
what's going on that was actually a
really good move
thanks for the advice three oh
uh yeah thanks for the three
there's a good uh ted talk actually
um it's about growth mindset
oh am i just losing
i'm just losing
how do i be tricky take my knights
please can i pin the rook oh i'm
actually surviving here
and it takes hyperpets
okay opponent wants to flag me or just
beat me
that's tricky very very tricky
i'm too slow too slow
uh if you if you google a growth mindset
ted talk uh maybe you can find it
i think it's called the power of belief
it actually mentions chess
oh this is a nemo line i had this
against nemo yesterday she played king
d2 and i took and then she took and then
i won a rook
is it gonna happen that's a cool trap
yeah it's happening so yesterday was my
first time getting it on stream this is
the second time
it just wins the rook
it's um yeah she also played rook h5
eventually she hung her bishop we we
we're playing the exact same game
i think she played queen g3 takes and
resigns oh i found it thanks for the
suggestion
oh nice
um okay so white saving the bishop
always play off six i'm gonna be safe
enjoy the situation
uh play this move
oh my is my queen getting trapped the
queen is kind of getting trapped
i have queen h1 only escape
i want to do this and then take
and the queen is very a very geometrical
piece
i will take your first still threatening
this
opponent saw it
up a ton of time
okay i also feel good game yeah it's a
cool it's a cool trap
like this bishop e3 line it looks solid
for light but
this move kind of comes out of nowhere
okay moving on
thanks again karasu morgan
wait is karasu mor did you change your
name
because there is another morgan mistaken
maybe related not sure
but thanks for the bits
always play f3
oh so black's just not castling oh i'm
getting made oh no
oh i played the wrong move order i
resigned ah
wow i've never done that so i'm supposed
to play
i guess i'm supposed to play d5 here
what is this
i was just playing like all the moves i
usually play
okay h4 is a blunder yeah
so d5 they're threatening b4
so that's what i'm talking about like um
when you lose a game like that
it's okay to be emotional like
maybe for a few seconds after losing but
you just have to go back and realize
what you could have done better
okay let's play a walrus
or not a walrus play a reverse grand
prix
oh i'm losing a pawn but the knight is
it's actually kind of a funny position
a very strange position
kind of a cool gambit actually
play i just want to get the knight to d3
and mate
nice smother made idea
maybe it will happen white's gonna
develop though
what is this it's a fascinating position
i don't have time to think
now this king is not happy aligned with
the bishop i was a mouse left from light
i think white intended rook g1 but i'm
not sure
i could move
i have no plan i'm just getting squeezed
or am i
stop hurting me oh i got forked
this position is very resignable
that's a cool opening
um yeah white
white found some nice moves to get out
of trouble
and to put me in trouble play e4
i don't think i played e4 this
tournament
okay so something kind of hippo like
let me go for this
attack the bishop
pin the knight
so i'm starting to trap the bishop with
f4
oh i'm getting forked but i have a
counter attack
i don't think i'm losing material here
f4 saves me
yeah we're having very weird structure
here
just develop
and bond cloud
um
yeah let's be careful queen g5 ideas
i think it's okay
upon salt okay let's trade queens
i like the position
and despite the very weird opening
okay now i really like the position i
have 75
of a cube on both both sides
okay let's take a pawn
oh i'm getting getting skewered but i'm
promoting
check and mate okay that was nice
oh so i had two
75 cubes where if you add them up it
would be 1.5 cubes
yeah 150 percent cube power
let's go okay play d4
going back to london top 100
a very tough tournament up one's playing
a stone wall
against stonewall i like to go for this
g4 idea
because after takes takes takes is h7
hanging
i also usually like to castle queen side
close things down on the queen side
i'm gonna defend this and then go for
this
maybe even go for f3
yeah we could trade there's bishop h4
hi eric from yorkshire you're have to
visit york sometime
oh wait york is that new york without
the new
that sounds interesting thanks for that
steven numbers
i feel like i've heard of that oh can i
get the cube
i'm getting a cube social distance cube
more like a rectangle
uh yeah let's
if i cubify it doesn't work but maybe it
does
i don't know i'm conflicted okay it's a
cube a very short-lived cube
now f6 oh free bishop oh it's not a free
bishop
oh free knights that was a free night
well that was dirty move
okay attack defend
i have four seconds what is this
take my e-pawn
i flagged ah that was such a cool game
too
i cubified for a very brief moment in
time
and then i pre-moved stuff but that
wasn't enough
oh yorkshire is in england oh wow
alexa tell me a fun fact about yorkshire
according to wikipedia yorkshire
formerly known as the county
chess with eye tracker could have been
an interesting idea the largest in the
united kingdom
because of its great size in comparison
to other english counties
functions have been undertaken over time
by its subdivisions
which have also been subject to periodic
reform
i don't know if i understood that a lot
of robots were talking to me at once
there
yorkshire yorkshire oh yeah yorkshire
yorkshire
hey it's akash akash that was a fun game
i didn't uh actually i was
disappointed in you you didn't pre-move
97 i wanted to trap you with b4
am i losing
uh ah 97 but then king
should all be okay
okay so i'm up a piece
going for free pawns
oh that's a good move
okay
um take a free pawn
i'll play knight g3
what is this
oh knight g3 okay
whoa it's a raid it's photochats what's
up photo chess i'm dedicating this fork
to you
it's a very picturesque fork
very photogenic fork thanks for the
chess
shout out to photochest reading with 97.
97 is almost my place that i'm currently
in
shout out photochest hope you had a good
stream
okay playing sasha gel man if you're
just joining
this is a leachate arena my goal is
top 100 my other goal is 2700 but
that might be difficult can i take on f7
i think this works actually a random
london trap
oh maybe it's not maybe it's not good
oh because takes and things are attacked
um good luck my name is
play this move
oh thanks my man well lugi appreciate
that
okay so i'm down
i'm down stuff
oh no my knight
jack where's my mate
let's defend like this oh no no no that
was a mouse slip
that was a mouse slip
um preventing queen five
there goes all my things this is so sad
i have zero seconds left
ah i wonder i wonder if this was
objectively just not good
it was fun though it was very like
kind of interesting
so bishop f7 yeah computer just doesn't
like it
the problem was when i take the rook
block takes and attacks the rook and the
knight
yeah queens are very geometrical
creatures
okay 50 points
ah no one's falling for it
why is it so popular or why do i why
does everyone know it now
uh i have to find someone to blame
actually this isn't so bad or is it
this is playable maybe f5 and g4
that's three pieces so if takes i win
the queen
okay let's try and convert this cleanly
take
it's getting messy though have this move
i have to take with bishop
okay now i'm more solid
i'm gonna go after the pawn
yeah i like and queen but i can queen
too
should make a gatorade commercial
okay um oh playing harsha again play a
reverse grand prix
um have to always be concerned about
this move
but this is kind of typical a grand prix
structure
very typical idea probably dubious
but it's interesting
yeah i just want like active play so if
takes takes it's hard to stop queen h2
meanwhile i want to play knight t4
because knight's pinned
there's f3 but then i take it if rook
here i play knight f3
actually rook here knight f3 takes takes
king g1 and then i mate
will it happen it's on oh no i i
played the wrong move i reflexively
pre-moved but it doesn't matter
it's the same mating idea
oh no my bishop okay
i said the whole line that should have
happened but i pre-moved
the wrong had to go for the inter meso
now this is what happens sometimes in
bullets i get too excited with
pre-moving
oh this person uh yeah uh crushed me
earlier berserking me
and took all my raiding so let's get
revenge
okay going for this very juicy d6 square
maybe not so juicy
okay here we go
so i want to put the bishop on e7
except not anymore
queenside castle never too late to
castle
i want to take here
i'm down on time
no i got mated i got mated
ah i have a queen wow that was made in
two
wow kudos to my opponent
i felt so good like the whole game and
then
it ended so unfortunately
so i'm hovering around top 200.
okay i'll mix it up i'll play e4
excandi time
scandy trap time c6
oh no c6
um yeah that's a fine move i think
it's candy time yeah
yeah unfortunately there's no like main
traps here
but there is some kind of danish gambit
like
common compensation
got the two bishops go for
a5
um so i'm threatening this now
let's not get meted
yeah box playing this well playing this
very well
i'm in trouble
g4
i'm in big trouble here athon's attack
too many times
how am i down so much time
please just get windmilled
oh i was not expecting that
ah at the one final trick
that game i just got outplayed
maybe i should um i should go back to
something a bit more solid
okay again trying to break into the top
100. okay folk beer counter gambit
a fun opening
seems like white's prepared here
i'll throw in this and then we'll trade
everything
oh tricky
what is this knight e7
very tricky so i'm counter-attacking the
bishop
oh
what's going on
just losing a night
i'm down two pieces
but it's still kind of interesting
i'll win the piece back oh that was a
good move
still weird compensation
i have a draw no i don't have a draw
or do i rookie three let's go
let's check okay somehow i'm not losing
gonna march the pawns
two queens are fun two queens are very
fun to play with
okay somehow i won that
oh so 101
a tough tournament
oh good job cave winning with the
england gabba trap
i'm so proud it's great to hear
okay this is a fun line because c7
sometimes
falls uh under attack
i'm very pleasant
i have to still be careful what a lovely
mug
doggy toggy
i just want to trap the queen
let's just be safe
okay
we'll play f4 f5
oh look at this move oh no my rook
but then 97 triple fork
okay now it's just a normal fork
defend all the pawns
oh queens can move sideways
my time
i'm going to try and be tricky with the
queen the goal is here and then takes on
f6
let's go
a lot of pawns here
okay that was nice
some nice geometry that game 100 let's
go
that's a nice round even number
they should give like a money prize to
whoever finishes exactly number 100
just for me
wait this opponent didn't fall for it
before i don't know why i'm playing it
again
i don't know why i'm playing it again
i'm poor life decisions
so i'm just down the pawn i have to keep
track of who
doesn't fall for it so i don't repeat
this garbage
the thing is the position is still
playable
kind of i'm down upon
what to do like c4
okay so there's a target
um
this is nice having knights so i'm
preventing f4
it's kind of an outpost
there's queen b2 yeah
g5 good move
play queen d4
oh i'm winning a piece let's go
um my rook is being hugged
okay i didn't flag man i um
yeah it's hard to pre-move as white in
these positions knights are very tricky
thank you jupa mars oh like a
combination of
jupiter and mars and the letter z
something with prime
okay the goal is to pass up or pass a
chess network
or maybe to play chess network
london time
it takes an e5 or maybe this first
go for this
oh there's a cool trap um 98 takes takes
and then queen d4
uh this still works because a thing is
pinned
oh it doesn't oh no it does work okay
good i was thinking queen g5 that i
could take
um bishop c4 win this pawn
taking let's take this way
go in for the kill maybe
or retreat
okay let's win a knight that was nice
so this is um this is actually a nice
pattern in this opening
this e5 move and if i guess if knight or
pawn takes and i win the night
if queen takes i'm just winning stuff
okay 71 hey pass trust network
on a streak four wins in a row
i'm playing zuber
who is this from russia
okay we'll play this setup
win streak bits oh thanks for the win
streak bits
appreciate that gmd illusion
preserve the bishop complete development
go for something on the king side
hmm
i like the position it is kind of tense
though
not sure where my king should go
i really don't know what my plan is do
some maneuvering
at some point i might want a castle i
still have casting rights
uh what to do
okay
okay g6 is weak
you can take oh that was a blunder
let's go dirty flag man that finish was
so dirty
oh well i won i keep the streak 56th
place
let's go so that's five in a row that's
my longest
streak of the tournament
yeah that was a very uh hard fought
tense game
okay so about 21 minutes left
pre-movie five
uh take this is actually a
exchange french
i'll go fishing
do this
so the goal is to keep the queen side
closed and then just go crazy on the
king side
and grandmaster who is this
i can play this move there's knight e1
i don't want to take that knight though
and then you want to only move
this looks good for me oh
we're going to draw i want to draw
i'm turning down the draw
i'm scared of that
i guess i'll have to do this and try and
keep attacking
also thanks for the dirty flag bits i do
appreciate it
um i just want to open a file
okay should win this pawn
in a shaky position
i don't know what i'm doing
ah that was kind of dirty but
that's acceptable what to do i was too
slow
and too weak someone's gotta fall for it
right
no no one's falling for it
okay this isn't bad white never took the
the pawn so i'm not down material
i'll have a strategic game
oh i can't play f6
now i can play off six
and position seems a little bit cramped
hmm
i'm losing a pawn or no i'm not
or maybe i am
go for activity just kidding i'll play
though
i'm not easy for white
i'm trying to set up and mating that
that didn't work
ah wait if i play king e5 was that a
draw
no only been twice ah
that's rough okay
so my my streak kind of died
at least my winning streak losing streak
is alive and well
let's play a walrus
looks kind of fun some kind of opening
success
queen is passive develop the night
um i want to go insane let's go insane
i don't really have any good discoveries
but i'm just trying to confuse my
opponent
oh opponent confuses me
how bad is this
this is pretty bad
e2 hangs
have this move
i'm so confused
am i winning no i'm not winning a small
hallucination there
i resigned ah wow that was such a nice
opening
i wonder i'm just curious like what do i
do here
i don't sack i just play better moves
whoa it's vanguard
what's up vanguard thanks for reading
shout out to vanguard
i appreciate it i'm playing uh
the lyches title arena it's been
it's a two hour long tournament we're
we're in the final 14 minutes
and it's yeah it's full of chess so
welcome
to all all the vanguard
people guten
what's the right or guten dag or guten
guten abend and danka
and thank you okay
let's try and win some games for
vanguard
oh i taught vanguard this you get a pawn
to e5 in london
and you enjoy life
okay so i'm up a night i have to make
use of the night maybe win another pawn
i could trade off the knight
now i'm up a bishop
okay so vanguard before you raided
i had lost three in a row that was my
first win in a while
oh opponents doing the trap
i don't have prime anymore but it was
fun being subbed
novelty i i play the novelty
that's such a funny novelty okay now
let's not lose the game
opponent was fighting mate triple
forkmate
i feel so dirty doing that but
that's part of life a dirty trick yeah
yeah that might be the title of the
youtube video
if this goes on youtube brilliant
oh i appreciate that
i've been i've been uh saving that
novelty
for a while now actually that so
this queen d6 move was mentioned in a
youtube comment
um
that i randomly saw well that's what you
get if you try that against eric
oh my thing wait i'm wait i'm worse here
or no i'm better positionally but i'm
down on time
i better not lose this classic
trick thanks for that
i do appreciate it it's going to take
work to not lose this
hello future me hello
be really bad if i lose this
what does this move
i think thankfully we're trading kind of
have never donated to your stream but
you earned this d
what
no i lost that i lost this oh
oh i'm so broken i got to play my
novelty too
i still lost it
look at this move it's a novelty right
the first game ever queen takes g6
ah that's karma yeah
i guess karma is real
i'm proud to play a novelty at least
i'll still go on youtube i think
make people aware of it
also thanks for the 1000 bits chess
again
and sloppy wizard condolences
and reverie or maybe maybe i'll put the
whole tournament on youtube
okay there's work time
okay the best way to
wash my tilt away is with some good
berserking grand prix
i'm a little bit worse here oh i'm very
much worse
this is kind of bad up on time though
ah i got mated ah oh
it's karma from the previous game no
okay walrus time
okay this is actually kind of a cool
little idea
white will have potentially four center
pawns
yeah i'm gonna sack the knight
because why not
wait i got confused why did i do that i
wanted to play this
but i was hoping for it's not working
except here i can take it takes i queen
h4
my mating
it's close to mate
queen a6 or this oh
have this move threatening queen g6
made in two let's go
okay that was a weird game
that was a really weird game not proud
of that but
okay play d4 oh i wanted berserk
no
i tried lefonging him it didn't work
oops i'm getting i'm getting karmad
stop hurting me this is really low
quality game at least on my part
still in the fight though take on g6
oh there's rook here let's go
at least i have time to calculate
queen e7 black has nothing developed
except these pieces
queen a one kingy two
okay i won that i didn't deserve to win
that but i won it
failed lafang leads to losing material
leads to
somehow winning seven seven seven
i'm 79th place
okay let's play something normal
this move free pawn
thank you fuv 77
almost my place
um
i think this is okay queen e6
so i have two rooks for the queen
looks decent
keep pushing pawns
just want to meet
yeah okay so i'm up a pawn
i'm up two pawns no i'm up on pawn
i can't count
but about to be up two pawns
pawns are weak that was nice
okay solidifying my place in top hundred
thank you erinol solving with prime
appreciate that has dania ever won a
title tuesday
because it's usually like carlson or
farruga
or kona vlad it's impressive
eric would you drink a tea called
teenage mutant ninja tea
what uh depends if it's
uh lacking poison
um let's play this move two things
attacked
but it sounds interesting kind of
oh my pawn
i could play go get it let's play this
move
i'm trying to get him it's difficult
i lost my beloved center pawn
did i just trap the queen no but the
queen is very
oh why am i losing stuff
okay i'm throwing maiden one upon sees
it
this is rough
this is very rough
it might be winning material though
there we go
attacking stuff
that was a good move i'm stacking the
queen
it's still an interesting position
please just get me to please yes let's
go
four seconds left opponent
fulfilled my request because i said
please
that's why you always say please kids
okay that was miraculous
i was very miraculous okay still trying
to catch up to chess network
two points ahead of me oh one minute
left next game could be the last game
it'd be nice to play chess network oh
playing this person
staffer gambit time
no bishop e3 was kind of dirty
but respectable kind of
play d5
i'm just down a piece
i'm still gonna try and fight
i'm trying to create some confusion
b5 i'm not sure if this does anything
i just want to have fun
how am i down a rook i thought i was
only down the piece
good move
um
oh that's a very good move
um
oh i resign i'll give my opponent
tournament points
okay well i finished top hundred that's
better than some past results
finished 84 points
um fun tournament congratulations dania
had some fun games uh it was probably
youtube worthy
if this goes on youtube hello to youtube
people
hope you enjoyed that ah my
back my back is hurting so much tennis
yesterday
foreign